on match day at colchester's community
stadium
the stands would usually be busy with
thousands of football fans
now they lie eerily empty league two
teams like colchester united rely
heavily on ticket sales
and kovit 19 has hit this club hard 40
percent of permanent staff here
have been made redundant but just when
they prepared for fans to return as
safely as possible
the government changed its mind so
you've done quite a lot of work to
make this stadium as secure as possible
yeah absolutely yeah so what we
what we wanted to do we we understood
that we could keep people
socially distanced by putting gaps
between bubbles and also sitting them in
every other row
we understood that our concern was how
someone could maybe get up during the
middle of a game to go toilet or go and
get a drink
without rushing past people that was a
concern so what we did we took
we made gaps in the seats and we put
steps so that if somebody's perhaps
sitting in
in this seat and needs to leave they've
got ways to exit without rushing past
anybody else and the whole of this this
row would be unoccupied absolutely
it was a blow for robbie cowling
colchester united's chairman
it was very very frustrating because it
didn't seem to make sense
when i looked at what things i could do
and then what i wasn't going to be able
to do so
you know i could get on an airplane i
could go to the cinema i could go in the
pub
but i couldn't come and sit in an
outdoor stadium and watch a game of
football
where all these measures have been taken
to make it safe so
it didn't seem correct i didn't
understand at all
so what exactly has the government done
to help
the furlough scheme was brilliant the
fellow scheme was brilliant to start
with but
in some sectors i feel it perhaps could
have been carried on it's like they've
sent out this
rescue boat with only half a tank of
petrol you know what i mean and it's
it's only got so far do you think the
premier league needs to step
in yeah without a doubt i mean the
premier league sits on top of a pyramid
right and it's a really proud thing we
should have in our game this pyramid of
the system that goes all the way down
into the non
you know non-league as well and the
pyramid sits on the top of that
and benefits completely from him so you
can go through players you see holly
watkins got a hat-trick at the weekend
he was scoring against kosher just a few
seasons ago when he was at
exit harry maguire the captain of
england i remember him at sheffield
united
so playing against colchester so and you
can probably go through most of the
england team most of the premiership
teams
and all their players have come from
grassroots
they've all played under nines under
10's football somewhere so yeah the
premier league
seems to think that we suck from it but
it's not the case
it sucks from the rest of the
um pyramid system so yeah it really
should step in and do something
are you optimistic they will they have
to i mean if they can't see it for
themselves i mean
if they think they're enjoying this
penthouse for you and they're not in
danger from the building that's
crumbling below them
they're mad they're absolutely mad how
important
are clubs like colchester to the local
community
i think it's massively important not
just to not just to the people that
support colchester united like i say
people come here and give blood people
come here and you know
get married people come here and have
weights people
come here for all sorts of reasons it is
a community stadium as i said more
people come here for non-football events
than they do
and you know it's a hub the very first
thing we did when they did lockdown
was we decided we wanted to be part of a
solution so we got in touch with all the
authorities and said look we've got a
stadium
if you want to come and use it if the
nhs want to use it in any way
do so we don't want any money for it and
we're not the only club we're not saints
every football club that i know has
acted in that way has done something to
be a part of the solution for the
pandemic we've got the covered tasks
around the corner we've got a cover test
going on on here now yeah and i say we
don't charge anything for that
we just want it to be part of a solution
and as i say that i think football's
stepped in our community boys have been
brilliant delivering parcels
our players have been ringing pensioners
been bringing the vulnerable
so i feel we've done our part but we
need a bit of help too
to give a sense of scale macclesfield
town recently went under
with debts that amounted to gareth
bale's reported weekly wage
but premier league clubs may feel that
too much is being asked of them
millions of pounds already flow from the
top division to lower leagues every year
and they too are affected by the ban on
supporters
in an interview this week the premier
league's chief executive richard masters
said
clubs feel they've been hit with a
quadruple whammy firstly that the
optimism of october the first has been
taken away
secondly that there will be a sports
bailout but it won't include football
thirdly that the premier league will be
expected to secure the future of the efl
while dealing with the implications of
having no fans until possibly march
and finally the opening up of
entertainment arenas within sometimes a
couple of miles of football grounds
without any road map for the return of
football supporters
the culture secretary oliver downdon
told sophie ridge on sunday two weeks
ago
that the premier league needs to play
its part and help smaller clubs
he's vowed to throw everything at
getting fans back in stadiums
sooner rather than later but critics say
the government needs to do more
firstly get the test trace and isolate
system working
properly that's affecting absolutely
every aspect of our life
and it affects our ability as football
supporters
to get back into stadia secondly get
football clubs particularly those
in league one on and league two and in
the non-league you know get them round
the table
or albeit on zoom at the moment and talk
them through
the logic of what you're doing and how
you think we can put together a plan for
football i don't think there's a social
problem that britain has
that can't be helped by sport in general
and football specifically so if
anybody in government is snobbish about
football i i don't know why they would
be and i think it's time they should
grow up because actually football is
part of the solution
in westminster you hear an awful lot of
people worrying understandably about the
future of the arts and the impact that
kobud could have
on our culture but for millions of
people coming to grounds like this
supporting their local team is the
highlight of their week
and for lower league clubs in particular
they're really on the brink
there are hopes that a bailout deal
could be agreed later this month after
the transfer window shuts
without it dozens of clubs will be
fighting for their future